hi i'm night shyamalan and this is the
wired auto complete interview
[Music]
there is no moratorium on when do you
tell the end of the movie
you don't ever ever tell them
m9 all right let's see what it says
what does the m stand for in m night
um it stands for manoj which is a very
common
name in india it's not quite as common
as michael or something here but it's
pretty common everyone would mangle it
in school
they call me mango or a million things
and so kind of
abbreviated to to m eventually
what was m night shyamalan's
first movie it's a feature called
praying with anger
and we shot it in india i was 21 years
old and we kind of did it the kind of
classic way
you know friends and family and borrowed
and did everything we could
and there was one moment that i remember
where i was really down and i was
you know didn't know what i was doing
and the sound guy came over the indian
sound guy and said
you remind me of it of steven spielberg
when he came and he shot
close encounters and i was like that
that like pumped me up and
you know you know it's just a words of
encouragement but it always felt like
he had ordained me to be something
special or something because he used the
word steven spielberg who was like a god
to me so
i it really it made a difference and i
you know got all excited and we finished
the movie
what is the m night shyamalan
trilogy ah well i don't really do
sequels so this was really kind of a
kind of a one-off
thing in my life when i thought of the
story of unbreakable it was
really complicated and very long and
then i realized hey i won't be able to
make this in one movie
maybe i can put it into multiple pieces
so
i made unbreakable as the first the
first movie uh
of that and hope that would make the
other two and then to to be honest i was
kind of
down about the reaction unbreakable when
i when it came out
so i said ah you know i'll go make other
movies and i went and made signs in the
village and all that stuff
and then many many years later i went
hey you know what i
i think i should come back and make that
the second movie of the trilogy which
was split and then i finally made glass
so
i was super lucky to to get to finish
the trilogy
in this kind of weird and interesting
way what is
m night shyamalan working on i'm
releasing old and i'm doing all the
press for old
and but at the same time i'm writing
this new movie
um it's actually a book that i optioned
and i'm adapting it i'm about halfway
through
to be exact i'm on page 54 of the first
draft
it's sitting there right now it's
actually i can feel the moment that i'm
on and i'm a little
you know what's gonna happen next i know
what the character just said
and something really bad is about to
happen right after page 54
so i'm i'm preparing how to how to
execute it but that's what i'm working
on right now
what does jim say m night shyamalan i
don't even understand that what does
that mean
what does jim say i'm gonna talk about
this is from the office
i don't currently reside in scranton or
in an apartment building in scranton if
that's really what this question is
is eb9 shyamalan in unbreakable yes
i play a a drug dealer in unbreakable if
you look carefully and
my family are all doctors and all i
still stayed in the medical field so you
see that works out great
is m night shyamalan in the sixth sense
yes
play a doctor see you see the themes
here is
m night shyamalan in signs yes
i had no medical connection and signs my
character but
i you know this is one of the bigger
parts that i played in science i play
kind of uh the person that's involved in
the death of
the family member of in signs and um one
of the fun
memories i have is trying to do this
really emotional scene in signs
and mel gibson is acting across from me
and he's the least serious human being
and he would
he started doing off-camera his lines as
if he was sean connery so in a scottish
accent
and i'm like the tears started to just
drive right back up and i was like
mel i can like i i don't know how to do
this i was feeling
emotional and now i don't feel and he's
laughing i'm like i'm not you i don't
know how to do this so now i'm angry at
you so now that's what you got you got
angry at you
but it turned out fine and we used to
take five which he knew was the best
thing
is night shyamalan in split
i'm i am not in split i don't think i am
is m night shyamalan in the village yes
uh very small cameo towards the end you
kind of see me with a hat
and in a reflection uh at the end of it
if you haven't seen it
it is m.9 milan in always sunny
i don't think i am in it but i think
they've referenced me
uh in in the show you know if they want
a cameo we can do it for real but they i
know there was a whole episode where
they were trying to get into one of my
movies they're so sweet and what a great
show that is by the way
how am night shyamalan okay how
how old is m night shyamalan what a
great
question at this time i'm actually
50 years old big birthday for me so uh
very excited and we're gonna have some
friends over
and all of that stuff how tall is m
night shyamalan
i'm like that i'm that height you know
where guys always lie about their height
you know it's like
you're close enough to six foot yeah i
am six foot ish everybody that's light
just right below six foot always goes
i'm sick i don't know and they pretend
like they don't even know exactly you
know like we haven't obsessively
measured ourselves constantly to get to
six foot
probably more like five ten to five ten
and a half something that well but who's
measuring really
how did m night shyamalan
get his start the moment i think that
the industry started paying attention to
me is when i wrote a
script that no one paid me to write
called labor of love and
everyone bit on it all these all the
studios bid on and i was in my
living in my parents guest room i know
there was no cell phones at that time so
you're getting all these phone calls
they offered 200 200 000 i was like two
hundred thousand dollars
what i mean my parents get somebody was
my sister's old room which was pink's
just to add to the
the drama of it all and so i'm in the
pink room and then
like 250 300 fox offered 400 the new
line cinema offered 500
and i was like what and finally i i sold
it to fox
ironically after i sold it and i was you
know it was pretty young and i hadn't
done anything
they actually fired me as director so it
was very very sad
a sad conclusion of that thing but i did
have enough money to go get a little
home after that
me and my wife were just married we
moved out so that was the really
the beginning i was hired off of that to
write stuart little and i became known
as a writer i think first in the
industry
how to contact m9 shyamalan well i'll
tell you how not to
you you don't throw things over my gate
to
you know packages you don't uh leave
things on my car
don't do any of that don't do any of
that you know i'm on social media and
you you can try to reach out which i
don't get to read everything but
sometimes you know messages really touch
me and and i respond so
and don't reach out to my parents
because they're always like this person
stopped by the house and i was like mom
don't
don't that you know they gave me this
i'm like mom just don't answer it
bryce dallas howard
m night shyamalan wow so this is just a
kind of a
this word association is that what this
is so bryce
um i saw in a play uh off-broadway she
was in a
uh shakespeare play i think was as you
like it and
uh so taken with her and i was writing
the village at the time so it was kind
of a period piece
and i remember going to see her in new
york and just knew the second
that the the show was over that i'd
found who i wanted to be the lead so
i went to lunch with her and i said hey
i'm going to do this movie and i handed
her this script and
it was really sweet where am night
shyamalan let's see
where did m9 shyamalan grow up i grew up
outside philadelphia in suburbs of a
place called penn valley it was
it was almost like being in a like a
spielberg suburban movie we're all on
our bikes
riding around the neighborhood every
every night after school and then try to
get everybody ring the doorbell can joey
play can this person play
and then we'd ride around and have
adventures and then have to go home and
go eat and do our homework where did m
night shyamalan go
to high school i went to episcopal
academy
which is outside philly that school had
just become
co-ed a few years before so there were
girls and this was the first time that i
actually went to school with girls
so it was a very um distracting
uh time for me those of you that have
indian immigrant parents you know what
i'm saying
very you know restricted and then uh go
to school with girls and they're just
sitting right next to you and the pretty
girls over there and
very hard to to learn algebra under
those conditions where does
m night shyamalan live i live outside
philly we consider ourselves
philadelphians even though we're right
outside philadelphia i'm going to philly
every week and
uh that city is very very dear to me and
protect it
you know with everything where is
m night shyamalan now is that an
existential question or a literal
question
i'm going to answer it existentially i'm
at the place where i want to make the
most distinct
pieces of art for the largest audience
i want the pieces to have teeth i want
them to be challenging
and i want them to represent me and i
have the belief that
the more distinct and different they are
the more they're going to resonate with
you guys
over time this is obviously about the
movie signs
is signs a religious
movie wow that's a good question most of
my characters in my movies i think it's
about some belief system that i'm trying
i personally am struggling with and
because i went to
i'm not catholic but i went to catholic
school for 10 years that you know
the form of a priest felt very very
natural uh
to me as somebody to kind of carry the
load whenever i talk about what the
movie is about if it's about ghosts or
comic books or aliens or
you name it those are really just kind
of the clothing
for uh a discussion about the crisis of
faith so
i know the the kind of the theories on
signs that you know
the aliens represent inner demons it's
accurate in the sense that
all of them are you know you know the
comic book story is about you believing
in yourself
um that david dunn doesn't believe in
himself and science is that same way
um about this world event and does this
have meaning for you
are we just gonna get you know are we
just food you know
is is there is there meaning in
everything and then he finds meaning
in this moment what was wrong with the
dog
in science movie my mind was thinking
that
uh you know as the aliens got closer and
were were nearby
the animals would be uh becoming violent
and irrational
um and and acting erratically and that
that was
one of the first indicators uh that
there was something around that was very
threatening sending them into
uh a certain type of place something
something something something
signs who played the alien in the movie
signs
gosh i'm forgetting that's the the
actor's name he's so
wonderful he was so giving i remember
his energy and his kindness
on set just the opposite of the alien he
was very
very gracious and and made us all uh
feel like we were doing kind of like a
higher art form like ballet or something
yeah a really wonderful man
[Music]
what does water symbolize in science
movie
water always has a kind of a special
place for me in my movies there's a kind
of a sense of
purity from it or rebirth it's often
used that way
in religious ceremonies my parents and
my mom especially who do
a lot of indian ceremonies they use
water in this fashion
um and you see it a lot in different
different rituals
you see it in a bunch of my movies and
lady in the water and now i guess in old
as well
um that kind of the proximity to water
it feels like there's some you know
magical property to it so
uh it always made sense to me that that
would be
the thing that burns off the demons
let's say all right
sixth sense what does the titanic and
the sixth sense have should i do this
other line
in common they both have leonardo
dicaprio no they were both number one
for
a very long time in the movie theaters i
think sixth sense was either five or six
weeks and titanic was ten weeks and
since titanic i think these are the two
movies that have been number one in the
movie theaters for the longest
i see that's funny that's funny too
is this sixth sense let's see what's
this say
is the sixth sense a three-act narrative
look at this film school
i'm not sure i don't it's funny i don't
really think like that but
i'm sure it's true because what feels
natural right is that kind of the setup
the conflict and then the the kind of um
the escalation and that third act to um
the resolution i think my movies have a
kind of a by the nature of them because
as a revelation there's
there's probably a fourth movement in
them in those last moments
in these movies as you realize something
or there's kind of a revelation of some
kind
i don't know if that falls into the the
three-act structure like that
what are the clues in the sixth sense
gosh you know
i'm sure there's many more than i will
think of off the top of my head but we
used the color red to indicate
the other world like nagging at him and
i think you know him staring at the
doorknob of the
the the the things that were not ripe
that his consciousness
uh is not acknowledging because he has
to stay blind essentially as he's
walking through life a bit
what's the twist in the sixth sense i
can't tell you that i just if at this
point if you haven't
you know seen it you just go go watch it
this is how you do it you go and watch
this movie
and then you find another person and you
ask them before you say anything have
you seen it and then if they say yes
then you can openly talk about it away
from others
kind of situation that's it that's it
there's no other way to talk about it
that's it
okay plot twist
[Music]
it's been bing all along
you